hey ho what's going on so i've recently
graduated the phd and during that time
i've written a lot of code which is
mostly garbage but i thought we go
through my
github and i'll show you the most
exciting
and useless things i've ever written so
if you're on my github
you're gonna find a bunch of things
including
video related materials such as like the
eclip music video
you can make your own music video right
here
[Music]
you should watch if you haven't uh
there's the minecraft neural network i
provide you with the minecraft
world if you haven't watched that video
please do it
gpustat which is a tracker
for gpu machines and sending it to a
server and then displaying it this is
what our lab uses
for seeing who uses which gpus
which is you know fairly useful i think
this is the single most popular thing
i've written during my phd
because that's people actually use it so
there is the flatland repository so
flatland is
something we did some time ago and then
i was a total slug and completely failed
in supervising the project
uh let's not talk about this you'll also
find code for our conference submissions
of course but then we get into
the real stuff s run is a little tool
that you can use what it does is it
simply copies
directory to a server via ssh
it then runs a script on that server and
then it copies back a directory called
logs that's pretty easy and
i use that all the time it's very good
if you have a bunch of code in a folder
and the output
is a directory called logs you're good
to go otherwise you'll have to change
this a bit
okay at that point i had no clue that
you could use temp deer to
make temporary directories oh god
look at this so it happened too many
times that i didn't do this from the
directory where
i actually had my code but from the from
the home directory
so it synced my entire home directory to
the server
so i just no
see this counts as ux no i'm pretty sure
it does
and this right here this is the crown
jewel
rat it is a system that manages my
experiments
so in rat there is a bunch of things in
here
there is a worker and what the worker
would do
is it would sit on a server and it would
listen to a database for new
experiments that it should run and if so
it will pull the code
from a mongodb so so that the queue is
an
is a is a redis queue and it would pull
code from
a mongodb and then it would run that
code
but it would only do so if the gpu is
free
so to change this rq thing in order to
check whether or not the gpu is free
you can see right here there's a check
of whether or not the gpu is already
occupied
and if it is occupied it would just not
do the task
and put it back into the queue however
if it is not occupied it would run
so the neat thing you can do with this
thing is if a lab mate of yours is
running on a gpu
you just put this worker on the same gpu
and then as soon as their job is done
it's like
boom you got it i'm sorry i'm sorry
but for the most part it actually
prevents you from interfering with other
people
you know that's pretty neat and your
jobs won't fail just because there's
already something on the gpu
so the core of this thing is you can
run an experiment config which means you
can
upload different hyper parameters and
then jobs would be generated according
to
those hyper parameters and i even built
in a hyper parameter
optimizer so you can give ranges and it
would
search through them either in grid
search or in random sampling so here we
have a
search strategy and i built in so much
stuff you can
merge experiments i mean look at this
this is uh
this is quite a bit of engineering going
into here
it even has a tensorboard thing whenever
a job is finished running the worker
would actually put it
back into the database and this command
right here will get me all the event
files
from tensorboard and then it would
actually label the directories
with the names of the hyper parameters
so you actually see
directly in the run name which
run has which hyper parameters this is
so freaking useful because
usually tensorboard runs are just like
run one
run two or the date or some stupid thing
confirm really
[Laughter]
no i i built this in to prevent myself
from doing stupid stuff but i also built
like an override flag
you know like there's delete all so as i
said this is
it probably doesn't work anymore because
i know the redis queue dependencies have
shifted and so on
yeah if you want if you want some
inspiration uh feel free
feel absolutely free to clone this
i don't want it anymore like when i
started uh systems like weights and
biases and so on they just didn't exist
so i had to run my own similarly
why plot is my attempt at writing a
plotting
library that works with tensorboard
events and so extracting data from
tensorboard events this is all
so useless right now except this uh
smoothing
thing that i got from sci pi
which was pretty useful then why pack
is you can tell my i'm very innovative
with my names
i think that's just a set of routines
that i implemented
for uh working with torch
and tensorflow again this is probably
all
useless ooh there's deep fool look at
that most of this
is completely useless now because these
things are mostly in the libraries
themselves
confront is what i use oh look at that
this is a part of rat actually this is
what generates the
products of configurations that's why
yeah i even wrote a readme i wrote a
readme
a small utility library to generate
cross-products of experiment
configurations
just look at the unit test and hopefully
it should become clear how it works
let's i don't think so i mean look at
that this is
beautiful look you can like spec out
something like this
you can see like so there is you want
sgd optimization and these are the
different step sizes and
you can sample and this seems like a
good
a good uh thing i mean there are
probably 50 libraries today that do that
much better than
than i ever could fountain oh fountain
was
my own data set library
like c410 it would it would download it
from a server and it would extract it if
it's not there
yes this all exists now in torch vision
and for the ml for nlp in hogging face
what a useless thing this thing right
here
i think so in tensorflow one
if new youngsters remember that
it was quite a bit harder to save and
restore
and do anything like this so this would
be a library
that if your checkpoint doesn't quite
fit it would restore whatever
is there and i think it would also if
the shapes don't fit it would do like a
random projection to make the shapes fit
and if they don't fit yet this you had
to implement like a graph operation
just to get the restore to work
this is a plugin i wrote for chrome
because
i was annoyed that i couldn't cite an
archive
article from the article itself so i
wrote a plugin
that goes to google scholar and scrapes
the uh
the google scholar bibtex entry in
directly to lot to
archive it doesn't work anymore but uh i
think there are other plugins now
these are actually good this is a
continuous compiler
as you can see it's not very uh
sophisticated
and of course i did write my own archive
scraper there was still a time when i
read all of archive this is not possible
anymore
but i did read all of archive for
at least certain lists so i had i had
many more than these lists
new papers every morning and i would
just
read through the abstracts in the train
and those are repositories from my
masters and so this is the first public
repository ever from the pattern
recognition class in my bachelor studies
what is here linear kernel polykernel
rbf
just looks like support vector machines
right
did i implement this here's an svm
classifier
implemented yikes
and this who who does that who does
private
methods with a dunder no that's reserved
whoever did this
passed me no non-linear svm
without any sort of automatic back
propagation
no no stop
yeah but this is a this is a a support
vector machine without
without sgd i think we used to
calculate support vector machines with
sort of a quadratic programming i think
that we got that from somewhere
in any case this was my very very first
public commit to github and it was
already a machine learning
lecture so i guess i had this coming for
a while
if you are uh interested in useless
repositories check out my github
i'd be happy to see what your github is
look like
so this was more of a nostalgia thing
but i hope
you still had a bit of fun cheers